let's go to the Trump situation so you
openly talk a lot about Trump it's not
like you're holding back because you're
not a republican you're not a Democrat I
don't even politically I want to put you
anything you're just objective about
everything what do you think Trump's
involvement is was this well I
definitely think you know mainstream
media likes to focus on either Epstein
Trump or Epstein Clinton I think the
Epstein Clinton relationship is far more
damaging than the Epstein Trump
relationship I think the Epstein Trump
relationship
um was mainly a social one I don't
really you know the Clinton stuff is I
mean we just kind of got into that and
it's pretty wild right the Epstein Trump
stuff doesn't seem to be that crazy in
comparison I agree but you have to keep
in mind too like I think a lot of people
whether you love them or you hate them
you end up sort of coming at his
background and who he is from sort of a
biased
standpoint if you're on one of those two
polarized extremes that we have today in
the United States right yeah yeah
totally so as I see it you know I wrote
a lot about his mentor Roy Cohn and that
kind of world and that's the person who
supposedly taught him you know the art
of the deal and we talked a little bit
earlier about this favor bank system
unsavory alliances you're working in
real estate the you know cement concrete
it's mob-dominated companies you gotta
you know make unsavory alliances this is
to make your business work and you know
this is a guy you know Trump is a guy
that inherited a real estate Empire
already there he obviously wants it to
succeed so he's going to continue that
same system right and he's going to
continue making those same alliances and
do what he can to be a businessman and
do it in his mind is you know be
successful right so I think that's sort
of how you get
you know the Trump we have today but
then again you have Trump uh have a
major bankruptcy in the early 90s the
bank that rescues him uh is Ross child
Inc which is the Wall Street branch of
the European banking family and that
particular Bank was also
um very close to Robert Maxwell it was
also very close to a guy named Sir James
Goldsmith it's also one of these
corporate Raiders from this period of
time in the 80s and actually Jeffrey
Epstein had a relationship with him
Goldsmith as early as like 1973 1971
somewhere in that ballpark so that
connection goes very far back actually
but Rothschild Inc that the guy that was
in charge of it was a Robert Peary I
believe his name is and so Robert Peary
decided to specifically recruit sometime
in the 1980s Maxwell and Goldsmith and I
think another associate of Maxwell and
this is coming from the New York Times
by the way
um as to sort of help them grow their
mergers and Acquisitions business that
was it was the Rothschild family sort of
Saw Ross Ross child Inc as sort of a
neglected branch of their banking you
know Empire thank you and um and they
wanted they tasked this Robert Peary guy
was sort of growing it and developing it
and so he brought in Maxwell and these
guys right and so this is um one of the
banks that's responsible for Robert
Maxwell's deal with MacMillan for
example and MacMillan is believed to
have to really be the way that Robert
Maxwell got his foot first from the door
of uh in New York City specifically
um because of their you know interest
their macmillan's interest there and so
then you have that same bank that's very
tied up with Robert Maxwell and these
characters uh rescue Trump from
bankruptcy so by the way if you're
watching this if you think this message
needs to be heard by others give it a
thumbs up and share with others because
that's going to help with the algorithms
if you think this is a message and we're
going to give the links to a book as
well at the end but you know why I don't
believe he has anything going and the
media would love to find something with
him and Epstein because if you did you
would have never done this on the debate
uh stage Trump pulls out a stunt and
brings out you know uh the the ladies
that he brought up I'm sure you remember
this when he brought Apollo Jones and
Kathleen Wiley and Juanita Broderick
there's no way you do that if you have
any link to Epstein because this is if
you do this a hundred times more of this
is coming back to you totally well like
I mentioned earlier the Epstein Clinton
relationship far more damaging than the
Epstein Trump relationship so if it's
Trump versus Clinton you know who's
going to want to bring up Epstein first
really neither of them I think uh
because again this unsavory Alliance
System it looks like Trump sort of did
that to an extent you know with Epstein
but like I sort of touched on earlier it
seems like he was closer to the Maxwell
or a bit of stuff right
um and that may be because of this bank
that may be because he was on the lady
galane and had sort of these this the
stuff with you know allegedly was Simeon
mogulovich or Robert Maxwell business
partner and organized crime guy and all
this stuff but again unsavory alliances
you know you have in order to be on top
in that dog eat dog world you know where
Trump inhabits right in New York City
you know maybe you have to do some
things that aren't so nice right
this challenge it's a challenging thing
because once you uh come into Fame and
money you get invited to parties all the
time and you don't know what party
you're going because typically here's
how the party invitation sounds like the
party invitation goes and says there's
gonna be a lot of who's who's at this
yacht party it's a Monaco style yacht
party it's a party being hosted at xyz's
house and you're like okay go I'll go to
the party yeah but then you go to the
party and the next thing you know
pictures are being taken and then
afterwards hey such and such was that
this person's part dude I just got an
invite I don't I don't know anybody it's
hard to know but you know you got to
follow the money right that's a
different story following the money is a
different story once you do business
with somebody that's a different story
then you're invited to a party but
sometimes like there's even a picture
with jelene Maxwell Elon Musk so hey
look at the picture here within I don't
know if you've seen this one or not sure
sure it's from 2014. yeah so he's had a
party well she took pictures a lot of
people even like Robert F Kennedy Jr
took pictures with her but they're as
far as I understand not really
Affiliated at all so I mean she was a
social butterfly she was very much in
these um Elite New York
Social Circles and you know that was
really what she did she was an
influencer right and you know there are
times when she used that to advance you
know these this particular side of
things that we're talking about the
shadier stuff but some of it may have
just been social again it's really hard
to know but you know if you look like I
did at some of these articles that came
out in mainstream media before Epstein
was Infamous even arrested the first
time
I mean it's pretty clear that people in
the Social Circles knew something was
weird with Colleen Maxwell and Jeffrey
Epstein so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]